[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich habe mir gedacht geschenke aus der
küche wäre doch mal was richtig cooles
was ihr auch jetzt an weihnachten
verschenken könnt gerade jetzt wo man
eben viele freunde und verwandte und
familie einfach nicht sehen kann aber so
eine kleine geste ist doch echt auch was
schönes und geschenke aus der küche
müssen nicht unbedingt bedeuten dass man
sie essen kann deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht machen heute so ein bisschen was
für die körperpflege zum entspannen zum
einen gibt es jetzt badekugeln und dann
machen wir noch eine seife und
vielleicht machen wir sogar noch ein
peeling für silver dawn also für die
bomben ich mache ja diese badekugeln
verwende ich später einfach eiswürfel
formen ihr könnt aber auch das gibts auf
den diesen badekugeln dass man so zwei
halbkugeln hat wie diese anhänger die
gibt es im bastelladen aber ich hab
jetzt gedacht kommen für was nicht
einfach diese eiswürfel form benutzen
die kriegt man da ja auch super wieder
raus weil sie ebenso ein silikon boden
haben und dann kann man eben auch was
nutzen was man eh schon zu hause hat ihr
verwendet dafür 200 gramm natron 100
gramm zitronensäure 70 gramm
speisestärke 100 gramm kokosöl und hier
habe ich noch ätherische öle und etwas
lebensmittelfarbe nato und zitronensäure
gibt es auch im supermarkt in jedem also
da könnt ihr gerne mal schaun atrium
gibt es in der buck abteilung
zitronensäure gibt es in der putz
abteilung steht sogar meist noch dabei
lebensmittel echtes echte zitronensäure
aber wie gesagt es wird der zeh nicht
gegessen sondern eben zum baden
verwendet
die zwei werden jetzt mal vermischt
habe ich eigentlich immer im haushalt
weil ich damit auch gerne putze und
reiniger selber hersteller
dann die stärke die bindet das ganze
das ist eben auch eine schöne feste form
bleibt kokosöl ist je nach
raumtemperatur flüssig oder fest als im
sommer habe ich es immer recht flüssig
in einem küchenschrank aber das ist im
prinzip egal weil es später sowieso in
den kühlschrank kommt okay das ist jetzt
die grundsubstanz das kokosöl
kommt jetzt auch ein
und da ist es einfach so dass kokosöl
natürlich auch die haut pflegt und so
eine gewisse in gewissen duftstoff
natürlich auch schon mit reinbringen und
es wird eben im kalten zustand schön
fest
jetzt die zutaten hier vermischen
[Musik]
und ich habe jetzt hier übrigens
handschuhe an einfach um die hände zu
schützen denn ich werde ja auch gleich
noch farbe benutzen und hier könnt ihr
jetzt mit reingeben ich nur mit dem
pinsel ein
paar tröpfchen das ist richtig
ich glaube ich werde sogar diese masse
noch zweimal herrschte denn dann habe
ich genügend sparte bomben und die lasse
ich jetzt weiß und die anderen zwei
fertig dann grün und rot
so fühlen sich doch so diese bösen gang
starte in der garage böse dinge am
löschen
[Musik]
da ich die brille wieder ausziehen die
sieht ja bescheuert aus
ich fühle mich so richtig bescheuert bei
der farbe einfach eine lebensmittelfarbe
nehmen die geht nämlich ganz einfach von
der haut färbt hat die haut auch gar
nicht in der badewanne eigentlich das
wasser bietet dann wirklich nicht
wirklich grün nur weil ich jetzt ein
bisschen grün drin hab aber auch grad
mit acryl badewannen aufpassen und
deswegen lebensmittelfarben benutzen und
die sind auch für den körper nicht
schädlich und eben auch für die party
oder nicht jetzt habe ich hier die
eiswürfel förmchen wenn ihr möchtet
könnt ihr noch kleine sträuße mit rein
geben also zuckerstreuer oder auch
kleine sternchen alles was schön
weihnachtlich winterliche aussieht
die gebe ich jetzt hier unten rein denn
das sieht man dann von unten
machen den komplementärfarben bei rot
grün muss bei wort die grünen streichen
aber bei weiß lass' ich glaube ich auch
ich weiß nicht ich mache es glaube ich
kontakt
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr hier einfach die masse
reindrücken und dann ist wichtig dass
sie wirklich reingepresst wird damit die
badekugeln später auch schön zusammen
bleiben ihr könnt auch in gegenstand
nehmen so sein holz zum beispiel und
richtig fest reindrücken ich hatte mal
so ein muffin form drücke aber wenn es
nicht mehr doch mittlerweile hat sich
die versuchs werkstatt vergrößert
nicht mischen haben wir gesagt bei den
ersten jetzt mit den restlichen dürft
ihr mischen ok dann lasst mich jetzt mal
kurz nein nein nein dann lasst mich
jetzt mal kurz fertig machen wenn du so
manch
und dann rein dann herrscht außen nicht
so viel was später dann habt euch nicht
weil es außen diese krümelchen die
fallen dann weg falsch
[Musik]
so jetzt hab ich sicher an gedrückt was
jetzt wichtig ist das ganze kommt jetzt
in den kühlschrank muss fest werden für
ungefähr 56 stunden dann nehme ich es
raus stützt sie auch heraus und setzte
dann aber etwa zwei tage trocknen lassen
dann wird das fett schön fest alle
flüssigen bestandteile trocknen und dann
kann man sie verpacken also das ist
einfach nur noch eine wartezeit die man
hat und wir machen noch weitere
puelacher vorne drin sind eis förmchen
fünf menschen
[Musik]
kommen wir zur zweiten idee nämlich
seife selber machen und ich habe dafür
seife bestellt also selber machen heißt
so viel wie seife aufpumpen ich hab hier
glycerin seife bestellt einmal
transparent einmal weiß wie ihr sehen
könnt
und dann nämlich auch wieder die
eiswürfel förmchen wobei ich hier auch
diese länglichen habe also diese stäbe
die nehme ich wahrscheinlich auch ich
habe hier verpasste in lila lavendelöl
und lavendel aus meinem garten und da
werde ich sie zu machen dass sich diese
schmelze
im in der mikrowelle im wasserbad geht
aber auch
[Musik]
ich glaube immer zwei weniger nicht das
ist mir über läuft in der
mikrowelle also kurz in der mikrowelle
verflüssigen
[Musik]
die zweite kamera kind samira an der
zweitkamera körper sie mal zeigen da er
die kamera hey
super job bisher super job
sehr gut sehr gut sitzt die schärfe
sehr gut also die seifen sind
geschmolzen
jetzt gebe ich hier jeweils lavendelöl
rein wie gesagt auch hier könnt ihr
wieder andere dürfte neben orange
zitrone was auch immer ihr wollt wo
rosmarin ist auch wohl im sommer seife
und ich neben lila verpasste jetzt auch
wieder lebensmittelfarbe ganz wenig ich
mich zum einen leichten flieder tun
haben
okay wer das kurz berühren damit sich
die farbe besser gelöst
[Musik]
ich denke es wäre auch besser gewesen
einfach eine kleine menge flüssigseife
mit der farbe zu vermischen und dann
wieder zurück es war mein fehler egal
ich hoffe du setzt sich wieder wenn
nicht schmerzt noch mal und machst du so
wie gerade eben vorgeschlagen
habe jetzt werde ich einmal stäbchen
machen und einmal so
und die jetzt hier befüllen bei einigen
wirklich am boden einfach noch lavendel
verteilen damit man sich doch sieht
[Musik]
die muss ich jetzt im prinzip nur fest
werden lassen
[Musik]
war das richtig hier echt lecker recht
gut
also die lasse ich jetzt hier auch fest
werden und dann gibt es noch ein
körperpeeling
die bade bomben habe ich jetzt aus dem
silicon formen herausgelöst die seife
ist auch schon fertig jetzt geht es im
prinzip noch an das dritte rezept und
das wird ein körperpeeling und da habe
ich jetzt bewusst ein körperpeeling
gemacht und keinen gesichts peeling denn
beim gesicht ist ja jeder so ein
bisschen eigen also ich würde jetzt auch
keinen peeling ins gesicht schmieren von
dem ich nicht weiß was drin steckt aber
ein körperpeeling ganze für unter dusche
jetzt im winter ist doch echt ganz cool
und das mache ich wie gesagt auch aus
guten zutaten weiß was drin steckt und
es ist einfach eine schöne geste ich
habe mich jetzt hier einfach für die
variante entschieden kokos honig und
brauner zucker mit orange aber auch hier
können sie natürlich den duft verändern
oder auch die inhaltsstoffe verändern je
nachdem wofür er eben brennt und was
euch so am liebsten ist dafür nämlich
160 gramm kokosöl 160 km honig 320 gramm
zucker reduziert den braunen zucker eine
orange und etwas orangenöl und das ist
jetzt wirklich super einfach ihr gebt
einfach die zutaten hier rein heute ist
das kokosöl sehr fest da die küche heute
sehr kalt ist
ich friere sogar ein bisschen nicht ich
sage und stadt kokosöl könnt ihr hier zb
auch mandelöl nehmen oder was komplett
anderes was er einfach wurde
honig
dieses peeling wird man am ende am
liebsten essen ich nehme es ihr den
braunen zucker wenn in den normalen
weißen zucker nimmt wird das peeling von
der farbe her einfach heller und ich
finde so siehts einfach so ein bisschen
ja einfach noch natürlicher aus sie
einfach verrühren und das riecht jetzt
momentan nach honig und kokos und ich
für feines mit orange aber auch hier wie
gesagt einfach und dürfte neben den ihr
mit bei der orange mache ich so dass ich
jetzt hier den abrieb mit dazu gibt auch
gerade so für die optik sie beziehen so
einen festen reise mit dem reise ich
sozusagen diese kleinen kügelchen hier
ab sich natürlich auch gleich extrem gut
weil die ätherischen öle sich verbreiten
und die orange und die presse ich
einfach aus und gibt es zu meinem wasser
ich habe ich noch einen orangenöl das
nämlich normalerweise zum backen ist
auch rheines orangenöl 100 prozent ist
sogar wirklich für die lebensmittel
gedacht zum
verzehr und das ist wirklich aus einer
orange einfach gemacht aus der
orangenschale und daher halte ich
einfach nochmal den konzentrierteren
duft
was auch gut passen würde vanille also
ihr könnt vanilleschote vanille extrakt
könnt ihr auch dazu geben und habe diese
orange vanille kokos
aber so gefällt es mir echt gut und
das ist jetzt hier diese konsistenz mir
gesagt wenn die küche ein bisschen
wärmer ist kann es ein bisschen
flüssiger auch seien durch das kokosöl
puzzle ist auch und super
feuchtigkeitsspender für die haut linda
ca hautreizungen und kann eben auch
antibakteriell wirken und deswegen ich
benutze es auch tatsächlich oft gerne
zum abschminken so kokosöl und dann
rosenwasser drüber und dann ist wirklich
alles komplett sauber und weg und jetzt
könnt ihr entweder so kleine weg
gläschen nehmen oder einmachgläser mit
schraubdeckel und die dann schön
dekorieren oder andere gläschen
ihr könnt aber auch hergehen und sagen
reagenzglas sind die sind auch echt süß
also da könnte jetzt im prinzip
entscheiden wie viel ihr praktisch vom
peeling verschenken wollt wie groß die
verpackten sein soll und wie es eben am
ende dekorieren wollte
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir noch spontane vierte
idee und zwar ein badesalz selber machen
dafür nehme ich hier einfach ein
bisschen grobes meersalz und getrocknete
blüten im prinzip ist dieses badesalz
auch zum verzehr geeignet also
eigentlich alles was wir jetzt hier
gemacht haben ausser die seifen und nach
die bade punkten im prinzip kann man es
zum verzehr nehmen wenn ihr hier
beispielsweise noch pfeffer dann dazu
gibt könnte ja auch sagen es ist ein
salat salz denn ich persönlich mag es
ganz gerne wenn ich getrocknete blüten
in einem salat habe ich mache die total
häufig rein weil sie einfach einen super
tollen geschmack geben das sind hier so
kornblumen hagebutte also eine ganz ganz
tolle mischung aber jetzt sind wir bei
die nonfood geschenke deswegen mamas als
badesalz und im prinzip mich einfach
beide zutaten zusammen je nachdem wie
viel er eben auch machen möchte
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr auch hier
wieder ätherische öle dazugeben
insolvenzen badesalz werden soll
eukalyptus pfefferminzöl alles was ihr
eben gerne im badesalz mit drin habt
und wenn es ein salat saals werden soll
dann am besten keine
orangen oder was weiß ich dass wir
spiele ich lebe jetzt hier einen
trichter und für die reagenzgläser
[Musik]
ich finde sowas ist nicht nur ein
hübsches weihnachtsgeschenk dass das
geht einfach immer
wenn man sich sowas auf vorrat macht ich
meine das wetter nicht schlecht sei es
wird nicht schlecht zucker wird nicht
schlecht dann hat man einfach immer was
was man auch mal mitnehmen kann wenn man
irgendwo mal eingeladen ist so zu gast
einfach immer so ein schönes selbst
gemacht das mitbringen von es gibt
mitbringsel das ist das was man mitnimmt
wenn man wohin geht und neulich habe ich
als ich las unsere mehr als
kindergeburtstag so geplant haben wir es
nicht dafür ja ausloggen bedingt aber es
stand noch statt im kleinen rahmen und
dann habe ich solche guckt nach mit gc
weil auf kindergeburtstag ist so dass
man den kindern was mit gibt und das
sind die mit gips und ich dachte immer
dass version dialekt wort bei uns hier
somit gipfel aber es stand sogar online
auf seiner kinder homepage so ein
produkt was man bestellen konnte so
diese tüten und da stand ich mit gibson
tüte
und gedacht so mit gibson mitbringsel
sagt ihr mal ob ihr das so auch kennt
guckt mal wie schön das aussieht und ich
nehme alles zurück was ich gerade eben
gesagt habe ich habe gesagt ihr könnt
noch ätherische öle zufügen eukalyptus
pfefferminzöl kurz nicht denn diese
blüten die riechen so gut
man hat so ein richtiges schönes blumen
bat dann also dass das richtig gut da
würde ich echt nichts mehr zu machen und
vor allem wenn ihr nichts mehr dazu gibt
könnt ihr sagen ich nehme es für salat
oder ich nehme es für zum warten können
dann entscheiden
mit die kurie zielgrade alle geschenke
und kann beim dekorieren fällt mir dann
eben auch ein wie man es schön hübsch
verpacken kann unternehmen verschenken
kann also was ich auf jeden fall machen
würde wäre so ein kleines schild dran zu
hängen das eben auch dran steht was drin
ist damit auch die menschen die
beschenkt werden wissen was sie eben auf
ihre haut streichen semira du kannst
vielleicht für dieses peeling einen
schönen löffel hohe oder sarah mal
fragen welche löffel farbe sie braucht
guck mal hier sind jetzt die vier
artikel artikel seine show die wir wurde
die selbst gemacht habe zum einen die
badebucht die man wirklich ganz einfach
in etwas badewasser auflösen kann haben
wir auch schon zusammen gemacht für so
ein kleines sprudelbad das badesalz was
man eben auch einfach in warmes wasser
mischt hier die handseife die man eben
zum händewaschen benutzt und das
körperpeeling und gerade das
körperpeeling muss ich sagen es macht
hat wirklich eine super geschmeidige
haut spendet feuchtigkeit und pflegt die
haut und auch bei den anderen produkten
muss man sagen dass sie die haut sehr
gut pflegen vor allem auch die bade
bomben auch mit dem kokosfett mit dabei
das salz ist natürlich einfach er so ein
kosmetisches produkt meersalz im
badewasser ist natürlich wunderbar und
durch die blüten hat man eben diesen
tonnen duft und lavendelöl muss ich
persönlich sagen ist auch ein einer
meiner favoriten denn ich mag lavendelöl
zum einen auch ganz gerne im gesicht
also auch mal zum abschminken und
reinigen oder eben auch einfach zur
pflege und ich mag es auch ganz gerne
weil es eben beruhigend wirkt also es
hat echt so eine schöne beruhigende
wirkung und wenn ihr das ganze eben
hübsch verpackt ich habe hier die seifen
so einzeln verpackt und die könnte
wirklich schön die geschenkpäckchen und
anhängern arbeiten dann ist es doch eine
richtig tolle geschenkidee aus eurer
eigenen küche und könnt ihr auch sowohl
mit kindern zusammen machen aber du bist
ja schon so ein großes kind du kannst
sowieso alles alleine machen ich kenne
hier sollen auch einnahmen
da hat man so eine seife war dabei so
zum händewaschen also schreibt mir gerne
wie ihr diese ideen findet und ob ich
gerne weitere ideen machen soll die auch
mal nicht essbar sind schreibt gerne in
die kommentare wenn wir mal weiter in
richtung naturkosmetik auch gehen wollen
und ich freue mich auf eure
rückmeldungen freue mich auf eure fotos
die ihr machen werde und jetzt gehen wir
uns warten oder
püriert aus seiner schnappen uns die
bade pumpen oder ich das badesalz und
das
[Musik]